[Music]
all right let's go to amy in los angeles
ca what's up amy city of angels how are
we doing
good morning how you doing today dr john
we're figuring it out figuring it out
what's up
same here
that's why i called you
so the initial question was
my husband bet
and well i know you don't promote
divorce but
at this point i just feel unsafe stuck
and to be honest i just don't trust him
anymore okay tell me about it
he said he bet does he have a gambling
addiction
yes
and so what's he put your family through
thank god we don't have kids so it's
just me and him
but it just has been a lot of
emotions hiding
lying of course
um what's the financial damage
uh
with debt and that probably up to the
100 thousands now that he's gambled away
yeah so he got out of hand for sure
yeah so
i will tell you this um i'm not a
like you said i don't condone divorce
there's absolutely some seat some some
situations that people need to run for
the hills what i don't do
99.9 of the time is i don't tell people
you need to get divorced that's a
personal decision that somebody's got to
come to
and
for you to start the call that way
with the words i'm unsafe
my husband's burned through a hundred
thousand dollars of our household income
how long have you all been married
five years
in five years how old are you
i'm 35. okay
for you to call with those challenges
laid out and to say i
i'm down the road on divorce that sounds
like you're already there so is that
where you are
yeah i already looked into
the paperwork and what do i have to do
because i don't want this to keep
affecting me on the long run
so i would rather
cut it right now where he's to be nice
of course he's
ashamed and
sorry and cried to me every night
and sometimes i think about it you know
to be like he's a good man i'm not
excusing him
has he gone to get help has he gone to
treat him no okay i i asked him many
times and
i feel like he doesn't think he has a
problem
but with all of this
evidence and
years of doing it and getting the same
outcome
so of course it's a problem now it's an
addiction yeah
and um
i will often give people grace on their
addiction
where i hold the line is when somebody
says
i refuse to
go seek wellness and seek healing
that's what i'll say that's the choice
so someone could say hey i can't control
this behavior it's out of control great
you can control whether you go seek
connection and support and healing and
um he's not made that choice two
important things for you to note this
has nothing to do with you
and that can that should be good because
often you can feel like i'm not enough
what is it about me that he that this is
more important that's not how that works
is that where is that where you are
yeah because um it's so fun to help
people it's like oh we just have a kid
he would change i just want to bring a
kid
he's like are you serious exactly that
mentality no i'm not going to be part of
that he needs to heal first
if there was a chance we need to heal
our marriage which at this point known
but i have done everything in my power
to help him and
yeah i feel like i was not enough for
him to stop that i need to bring another
little
picture here no no that's not a don't
don't go down that road
no i won't
the road to go down is this
you can control two things in the world
yeah the thoughts you let circulate in
your mind that you meditate on that you
spend time on and your actions that's it
with a period you can't heal him you
can't do some
new thing that's he's going to be like
oh i didn't think about that i'm going
to go make this he can't do that right
and i don't take it away from him i'm
i'm
call me what you will when it comes to
addiction man um but from people who are
workaholics to urnaholics to alcoholics
and everyone in between
i have a real soft spot in my head for
people who struggle with addiction i
really do i have a soft spot in my heart
i get it
and
when you make somebody unsafe you force
them into making hard relational choices
because you won't
and that's where you find yourself
you're not safe
and so i'm not going to tell you to
leave him i'm going to tell you that you
can only control you
and that you're worth being well and
you're worth being safe
okay yes
i believe it
and
even the right decision here
is gonna be painful the choice to stay
and to work it out and to yell and
scream and demand he go to treatment
is gonna be painful the choice to leave
and get divorced it's gonna be painful
and so when you hurt in the next month
two months five months seven months nine
months
the evidence of i mean the the feeling
of hurt is not evidence that you're
making the wrong decision
you don't have a way out of this it's
not going to be painful
okay
you have to decide i'm worth being well
and i'm worth being safe and
at this point my husband is not is
choosing to not go do the things that he
needs to do to be well
and i'm so
heartbroken for you amy i'm so sorry
thank you
i really wanted to make it work to be
honest
of course of course
of course have you ever have you given
him the or what statement have you said
this is the line
okay i've been five five years married
seven in a relationship
and that's the thing like i saw the red
flag since the beginning and but i guess
when you are in love
you lose track of those five senses or
sixth sense
and the fantasy
the fantasy is so strong yeah it's
beautiful were you um were you had you
been married before or were you single
until you were 30
no i was married before okay all right
so this was going to be my 23rd
this is going to be the one huh
yeah of course
he was do you have some shame in your
heart and mind that
it didn't work out again for a second
time
no to be honest no i'd rather
that's a way
yep
i'd rather step away and find my
well-being that stay in a relationship
that's just not working well it's less
about
again it's less about just not working
and more
you were unsafe and the dishonesty and
the hey we're one
bad evening away from being homeless and
foodless and retirement-less
this is you out on the plank and you are
waving in the wind here this is a scary
scary place
and your husband's struggling man he's
sick and he needs to go get healing and
my heart breaks for him heartbreak's for
you guys smart breaks for your marriage
but
whoo you're worth being well
and i'm so
i'm sorry about this this this one's uh
this one sucks too man